thank you
[Music]
it might look like nothing or it might
look like Starship Troopers oh yeah this
is the beginning structure of Troopers
that looks like that at the beginning
that looks like boot camp of some sort
right that's a lot of soldiers huh it's
definitely the beginning of Starship
Troopers whoa that's a lot of humans
so what that is it's 10 000 soldiers and
cops
that are surrounding an entire city
to hunt for gang members ten thousand
bro they ain't messing around here
I'm like crazy
10 000 homies like that can you imagine
the [ __ ] friendly fire oh no I can't
especially because we did Airsoft
yesterday and we had friendly fire with
10 people I've seen each other all day
dude we lost a leg out there they're
blocking all the ways out of this
Township called soyapango soyabongo
that's a [ __ ] gangster they're not
messing around bro when we went there
there was a military there was like uh
military police like everywhere
everywhere we went felt very safe you
went to San Salvador uh yeah uh in March
or April so it was tight why'd you go uh
my wife's family so you went to Go Peep
game and everybody was like you better
watch out you're gonna get killed by
MS-13 but it was actually like very safe
I heard El Salvador's doing a major
Crackdown because they're like we need
to boost our economy and these guys are
controlling our economy and like yeah
it's pretty actually kind of dope it
says that the uh they were the people in
power requested Congress Grant
extraordinary power after gangs were
blamed for 62 killings on March 26th and
that emergency decree allows them to
suspend certain constitutional rights in
order to arrest and hold suspects oh
[ __ ] no different than us dude there
were some moments where we're driving
through like certain like neighborhoods
and it was like it's kind of scary
because I'm like [ __ ] dude I'm like a
[ __ ] little chinito driving yeah and
then like you see these military police
and they look mean and scary as [ __ ] and
they were like searching people's cars
as they went through and then they saw
us and they're like oh yeah you guys
come through and I was like oh [ __ ] like
I was like trying any chance I could get
to avoid him I was trying to yeah yeah
they were like super
super extra nice because I think they
knew we were oh yeah didn't somebody
call you a chinito
not there no no what kind of ching chong
are you do they say that yeah they get a
six-year-old Mexican kid go
sh I wish that would have been the
cherry on top of my experience I think
so what you know are you familiar with
like this whole Crackdown in this
operation a little bit not really though
I'd rather hear you talk about it go
ahead I mean you were just there weren't
you yeah are you guys negotiating but
yeah let's negotiate I hear you talk
about it
I started that special thing where
they're like okay give us the allowances
to do these operations murder has
dropped 38 oh that's dope that's good so
instead of 300 now it's like way less
it's like Duarte and drugs let's go
I feel like this is what Mexico needs to
crack down the cartel except I don't
know the cartel might that might be the
picture of their cartel yeah
it seems to intertwined though I think
so it seems more like opposite sides
yeah Mexico you need overwhelming Force
like that though to drive [ __ ]
out seems like it's the same [ __ ]
side a little bit when we were talking
about locals they were saying like a lot
of the uh police has been arresting gang
members everywhere and then the rest are
all in hiding like a game room just like
scattered because they were like oh if
they find out you were gang affiliated
they will arrest you they do something
is this El Salvador where they did
something to the graves yeah they were
like smashing Graves and they're like so
any gang members who were like yeah the
prisons are crazy what did they do in
the prison like I I don't know how long
ago this was they start doing them yeah
like they put them in these like they're
down here naked and they're like
squatting butt to like uh dick to butt
and these tiny little like chicken coops
in their prisons like the vice did like
a documentary about it and they were and
you see the pictures and you're like oh
dude this is not ideal for anybody so
they don't have the same obviously
things that we do here where it's like
no each prisoner has to be comfortable
and have everyone gets a Tempur-Pedic
match
yeah like I think it's a different scale
I think it's one phone per ass yeah but
once again I'm probably very ignorant
about it yeah yeah no Nick that's very
clear um you have uh fine details about
everything and then you're like ah but I
don't know
my surface level they all get
all getting chicken today and yeah
yeah they've jailed more than 58 000
people
agency was declared but then uh of
course you have their you have rights
groups as well um in these places and
they're criticizing the mouse Roundup
saying that they're just sweeping up
young men based on their appearance or
where they live
but yeah there's just so many gang
members that it's like the whole
Community yeah I mean Affiliated maybe
you know I don't know I don't know I'm
sure there's some people in there that
aren't really gang members that got
wrapped up like yeah like one of um
my wife's like uncles on her dad's side
he was arrested for like
15 years just because he was a driver
held at gunpoint by some gang members
and they arrested all of them and he was
in jail for like 15 years he was a
driver he was a driver he was like a bus
driver and they put a gun they put a gun
like yo you [ __ ] drive to make an
example out of them now other drivers
who have guns on them no
that they're going to jail too
so it helps yeah I'm surprised that the
gangs didn't Infiltrate The Salvadorian
government that's what it seems like uh
they maybe that would be the next step
and maybe that's what they're trying to
nip in the bud because they'll become
like Mexico you know yeah integrated too
much or did a rival group just go can
you just knock out my rivals well do you
think like always do you think in in
Mexico if they were to Stamp Out the the
entire
um you know like the drug trade and
everything with the economy itself take
a hit in El Salvador no Mexico oh yeah
for sure yeah of course yeah for sure
right it's a huge hit yeah that's Jesus
Christ it was a hell of a yawn thank you
for calling it out when everybody else
yells on this [ __ ] show Ryan
that's a hell of a hell of a day hosting
we're still getting out here late huh
Jesus hey um can we comment on Nixon
that's the best part of this video
he's doing an impression of a turtle
editor don't cut out can you guys just
play it twice and once in slow-mo for us
please the crazy thing is they're
calling this phase five of the crack no
host code here dude no [ __ ] host code
what is the what is the things this is
why I [ __ ] bought this you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I don't know they didn't say but this
apparently this like crazy part is Phase
five wow is it five of what like it's
like Defcon is it like Defcon though
where it's like five is like the most
[ __ ]
[Applause]
it's like the scariest time I forgot but
there's like definitely like big
security measures of when like shit's
about to go down or [ __ ] hit the fan and
it's just like we're gonna do whatever
the [ __ ] I don't think we've been at
Defcon even five since like 9
11.4 like forever what happens in Defcon
what is it what's the protocol it no it
has to do with nuclear bombs I don't
know what Defcon even means and I
thought it was is it Defcon or is it
death it's a situational awareness or is
it complex stuff which one is it it's a
situational awareness of the US military
like as a as a whole all branches right
how alert they are how high they are
like that is Defcon
are the aircraft carriers surfing around
the Pacific Ocean and everyone's playing
basketball on it yeah yeah or is it
surfing around and there's [ __ ]
missiles in every [ __ ] Direction yeah
and sometimes playing basketball a
little bit Yeah and on all the bases are
people bullet hollering at chicks on the
bases or is everyone and ready
information to deploy our pizza Friday's
done
funnies like most people don't know what
Defcon is but then when Kanye said he
was he wanted to go Defcon everybody was
mad yeah yeah but like no one knows that
really means but they were like don't
say that I feel like Kanye made it cool
DEFCON 5 means the Coast Guard has
binoculars and they're like all right
we're looking for [ __ ] we're on the
lookout and how do you spell Defcon Def
and then the Coast Guard's like man
everything's really far away he's like
hey buddy you gotta turn around oh I
appreciate it
[ __ ] you coaster
a lot of Coast Guard listeners I don't
know if this is like a low number but
you know in that picture where they're
trying to um
arrested gang members and there's like
they're in front of the town I think
they got 50 of them that's good
if you would this kind of Crackdown
who do you ten thousand look at them we
look at them right and then we're like
[ __ ] your guys's country is phys is yeah
visibly corrupt do you think they look
at ours and they might even think we're
in a more [ __ ] position because ours
is so integrated I think they like it we
need to surround our White House
probably oh if we need a clean house
what was the Pentagon budget how much of
it was accounted for [ __ ] oh yeah 50
something percent they can't account for
it 30 30 they account for which by the
way that's an f grade but then they're
like oh you know we think this is a
satisfactory way of looking at this [ __ ]
I think they're gonna find it they're
gonna find it the styles of corruption
are definitely different not that one's
worse or one's better but like migrant
numbers don't lie more people are coming
here still as much as they go your
country sucks like more people are still
coming over so it's like there must be
advantages well the fundamentals of
America are said I think you can play
the game easier here than you can in a
country like you know Mexico like if
you're trying to play against that you
kind of have to cooperate with the
cooperation like or the corruption
they're great from a third world country
and you have that kind of work ethic and
everything you'll just it's so easy like
as in like out here here like compared
to what it is back at home that's why
they come here because then they can
make money easier yeah and then they
bring it back home and then the value of
the dollar is higher yeah yeah yeah and
you can kind of make it okay minding
your own business doing a trade you know
you can just like learn a trade kind of
keep to yourself [ __ ] make your money
and bounce but other countries it might
not be that easy yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]